all right
sam yes sam where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i grew up in uh
spring texas just a suburb outside of uh
houston north houston specifically
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents um
well my mom and dad they uh
they are always uh fighting ever since i
was uh
when i was younger and and they uh
divorced when i was about 12 years old
and my both both my parents were
alcoholics and um
very dysfunctional in the household and
there's a lot of abuse you know
how many do you have any siblings i have
one brother
older brother um 16 months older than me
and uh he's a lot bigger than me and he
always beat me up growing up all the
time
um how would you describe your childhood
um you know it's kind of bittersweet you
know i just
i i love my family but uh
things really grew between us real quick
and um
it just really broke breaks my heart you
know more and more every day
just as years go by and i wonder if i'm
ever gonna see
my father again you know and um
it really does tear me up inside a lot
but um
i didn't get to see my uh
own father growing up very much because
uh
they divorced and by the time i was 12
and
i just saw my dad every now and then
my uh stepdad was also an alcoholic and
a drinker and he um
he uh often would hit me and i was the
only one around when he'd get drunk and
he'd usually take all his anger out of
me and it was just a lot of
a lot of hate anger growing up
just a lot a lot of uh bad
bad memories honestly growing up as a
kid i'm sorry
so you left home at what age i left home
at um when i was the first turn of
about uh i first got kicked out when i
was 15 but
i came back a few times and then i
finally got kicked out for good when i
was about 17.
and at that time i started living with
my aunt and i actually did get to
graduate
high school and things like that but um
would you like to go after after that
is really when i took off to
kind of a little bit of drug abuse when
i was a kid about especially when i
started when i was about 17
and um i had a lot of
friends still growing up after i
graduated high school and we
we just uh did nothing but partying it
uh my best friend he overdosed when he
was 18
um 19 actually right after we graduated
and um that was my best friend you know
we
lived and worked together did everything
together
um and he passed away
yeah he passed away when he was 19 right
after he graduated
and um so after that that's when my life
really kind of took off towards
around like 24 it was uh
um i've been actually on the streets
like about
honestly more like right after 17 all
right
uh was when i was first on the streets
was uh
right after i graduated and um
that's when my life really took off
towards you know homelessness
and and and drugs and just uh
pretty much been going from different
city to different city i mean
like every week or less than that like
i'd be in a different city
ever since i was in my early uh 18
20 and i'm 28 now and um
i was just always in a different city
like just
being homeless and it was just terrible
i couldn't ever
find anywhere that i felt like i really
liked enough
and and uh
that was just the time when i just spun
off to
towards like um
i went from living in texas i
went all the way north in texas like or
to central texas and brian college
station
i lived in amarillo just for a few
months then i
got so tired of living in in rural parts
of texas i i moved off to
colorado to see what it was like living
out there and i stayed there for a
couple years
and um and i
had a few jobs in between but nothing
really
solid and so i didn't have very much
ties there i had a lot of good friends
but
i moved off from denver to chicago
to um florida to uh
seattle um portland oregon
and then i started making my way through
california and sacramento
and it's just it's just uh i've been
hard ever since um
and you've been on skid row for how for
how long uh it's
it's been like a week now i just got
here and
i just had my uh just lost all my uh
my identification i'm really in a bad
position you're not really here
until you've lost everything yeah you
lose your id and
yeah i didn't realize i didn't have it
bad till i lost my id
you know like that's when
things truly set in that this is really
bad right now
yeah and what do you uh
what's your drug um heroin heroin
how long you been using heroin pretty
much since i was 17.
yeah that's right when my friend died
after we graduated
you can find heroin all over the country
yeah not so much in the northern parts
i'd say there's a difference in
north and south and east and west it's
everything's way different
how is it different strengths and things
like that
certain parts in like the middle of the
country or probably like where it's
weaker and it's not so much
of that type of stuff going on like it's
a
good way to get celebrities to go north
northwest
probably because if you're struggling
with that
because it's uh
some places it's almost non-existent in
some places it's
all over the place where where is it
non-existent
i would say right in like places like
arkansas or
nebraska and things like that
i mean there is stuff in uh the north
northwest
like seattle but it's just not not quite
like
stuff in the south yeah it's
definitely not like here where yeah
every block you can find
yeah fentanyl and all kinds of stuff
like that
depends on which block you're on yeah
yeah i didn't didn't know that that was
going to be a thing here
but yeah be careful here
yeah it's easy to get trapped oh yeah
what uh do you have children or anything
like that
no i've always been single you ever been
left
i've been in love when i was um about 23
i think
i was with a girl for a while and
i kind of try to hide my addiction as
much as possible but she kind of
she kind of knew because she's been
around it
a lot and
there's just times where i was so
intoxicated i couldn't hide it you know
yeah it's got to be hard to hide
yeah someone you're close with
yeah she even used to get high but she
tried not to like
when we were together and i mean she
really wouldn't
like she kind of had a thing against it
because she's lost her friends from it
but yeah how long did that relationship
last it was about three years
i really felt in love with this girl for
a long time but
she was still kind of uh i don't know
kind of broke my heart a lot
and just the way things would happen
like
um i just catch her sometimes hanging
out with other people and
other guys and i just kind of tripped me
out a little bit i was like
it just really broke my heart it was a
time in my life where i was really
addicted and i just could not get off
even uh all kinds of party drugs too
like i was when i was 20 in my early 20s
when i first turned 21 was
when i was just really just always
on it and when i was 21 it was one of
the times when i got out of being
homeless
and i actually had money and i was kind
of functional
and i worked with some of my friends
like
kind of worked around my addiction and
and kind of was functional as possible
and had people that would help me like
if i was too messed up going to work
would
help me sober up and stuff like that you
know because there were people i was
close to
kind of but yeah
that was my first relationship though
was about three years and
just really heartbreaking all the way
through
did you blame your addiction for kind of
ruining that relationship
yeah i uh definitely acted
a fool way too much and uh
and uh i was always so paranoid about
her
going maybe like cheating on me and i'd
always accuse her of that
and uh i think that kind of really uh
didn't do so good for me in the end that
i probably just screwed myself
with all my paranoid stuff that all my
paranoid [ __ ] just
pretty much made it come to an end like
real quick you know
and everybody said that would happen
and how do you support yourself now um
now
well i uh when i lived in chicago i
actually had
a brief time of success of uh doing
sales
and i made uh pretty good money and um
that was another time i wasn't homeless
but it was only for
uh maybe a year and a half and
um but
i try to support myself um on
the odd jobs i could get or uh
right now i'm without an id and i'm kind
of having to
come up with something you know i i'd
i right now it's hard to say i'm gonna
have to
try to order new id online or something
that's what i did last time
but uh yeah my life's just
i mean it goes good for a little bit and
then i i go
off and do a tail spin back on the
streets and
just same spot every time have you a
deed before
yeah i've od a lot
many times when i was growing up in
houston when i first started
and um and i've even known
indeed uh maybe once uh here and it was
a shock of my life i
really scared the hell out of me when uh
you
you overdose and you feel so cold when
you wake up
and that's because you were dead and
almost limp you know
that's uh a horrible feeling to ever
come up from that feels like the worst
body aches and the worst kind of mental
anxiety
goes on in your head when you come
through that
that uh you don't feel right at all
i don't know how to describe that
sensation of being resuscitated but it's
just
back to life you know it it's actually
really painful
it's really painful mentally emotionally
physically
it hurts it hurts and you your body is
freezing cold
it's one of the things i never even
thought would happen
but it it hurt really bad being brought
back to life and
felt physical pain from it did you feel
like your addiction
your heroin addiction is somehow
something you picked up
from your your mom or genetically or
your
even yeah your stepdad it's hard to say
because um
you know uh i know like
genetically my my actual dad was not
much of a
uh that much of a drinker as much as my
stepdad was but
um or an out or a drug addict or
anything so i don't know about
genetically but like i know that
um the abuse i think
you know getting beaten by my brother
and my stepdad
was uh it made me feel
kind of weak and small and just like
defenseless and it made me just feel
kind of
worthless you know at times when i think
that had a lot to do with it
that and um
i just feel times when i like was really
young
like just extreme stress and fear about
life and
i just felt that pressure and i couldn't
relieve it ever you know like
i just had a lot of pain in my heart and
almost felt you know pretty suicidal by
the time i was about
15 16 17 you know i was just
really uh really a damaged person
already you know
and um but yeah i just uh
i think it had a lot to do with uh
just uh being yeah my mother was also
would
really make me feel she would scream at
me all day and
it would just make me feel so so low you
know
and just so do the drugs offer some kind
of like
escape from that yeah it um
it really did in the beginning like i
felt like there's still i felt a lot
that there's a chance in life that
and i had a new group of friends and we
pretty much just
partied and and we worked and it felt
kind of functional for a while you know
like
um yeah it's just um
sorry getting distracted um
but yeah uh shoot
do you have friends out here um or
anywhere
yeah i got a lot of friends in colorado
uh pretty much all my friends back home
are
either dead or i don't talk to him
anymore
um i really don't
honestly know anybody out here and it's
really scary at the moment
it's really really bad it's uh
something i just hope that eventually i
i uh
i do get back home and see my
father again maybe or even my brother i
mean i just want or my and my mother i
just i want to see them again you know
it's been so long since i've ever
even seen them with the the abuse that
you
went through as a young man
how did that make you feel about
emotions um
just like i was just stupid and
worthless and in
wasted space you know like i was just in
the way of everything and
and that like they just treated me
almost differently than everybody like i
was just everybody's
uh whipping post you know it was like
uh i felt i always felt like i just
wanted a break from all that crap
i mean i couldn't just ever just relax
and come home and i'd be happy i just
there's always something something wrong
you know
i just always felt so worthless you know
growing up that
and like there must be something wrong
with me you know like
everyone i grew up with was was a lot
more into fighting than i was and i was
more about
peace and everybody i grew up was just
so confrontational and i just
i'm kind of a shy person and
i just i can't take you know yelling and
confrontation very well i just
backed down easily you know like i just
don't like getting in the way of things
and just it just pretty much scarred me
all my life
do you see do you have any hope of of
kind of getting your life
back in your hands you know i i clean
getting a job
stuff like that it's it's it's so like
right now it's like i was feeling that
way a little bit
i don't know why traveling kind of for a
little bit i
i got you know to get a little bit clean
and healthy for a little bit because i
was out of my elements and
i didn't know how to do things in other
places
and i just kept going town to town and
uh
i didn't really have very much time to
do things and i actually managed to get
an id
that i did online with someone and um
you know it's just uh
recently i went through a time where
somebody was helping me
and they were taking me different places
and
i mean i bought a they bought me a 300
phone
and i lost it and
i i had my id and a phone for a little
bit and i i really
had a lot of hope like just recently and
i
i had a rich friend from germany
actually that
he took a kindness to me that i don't
know he just felt sorry for me or
something it was kind of an interesting
experience when i
was over in chicago originally and he
was helping me get on my feet
and there's a lot of a lot of help
actually like he actually had
must had a lot of money and he he was
just there to
help me and he just felt really bad and
when he uh kind of just had to go back
to well florida i mean he was originally
from munich
but um
i i mean yeah i did think there was a
time just recently where i could get my
stuff together and
maybe enough to go see my mom and my
brother
and and um
and how it's it's gone back into the
negative like
i'm already lost my id i don't have a
phone to
talk to anybody anymore i'd at least try
to text my
mom and dad every now and then and now i
don't have any of those things in just a
brief instant it just happened just like
i thought it would you know
i just lost it just random
uh randomly just on the streets you know
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
i mean lessons i've learned is
as that you know you only live
once and and and that you uh
you wait ten if you're like me anything
like me you'll
waste a lot of years just doing nothing
and
nothing with yourself and you're never
going to get those years back
and i'm just so scared about that
because uh
more and more years go by and and i i
just
i don't know if it's ever gonna get
better if i'm ever gonna see my family
again
because i still care about them and it's
just
i've just learned to
sometimes if you don't know your limits
or you don't know how strong a drug is
you you
you could never wake up you know to that
that's a
a big thing that you could you could
always
um you could never
uh do less you know
and um
and it's just it's important to get your
uh
your situation straightened out not to
procrastinate and
wait more and more time like maybe i
could just
wait another day till i go take care of
that chore
that uh you know thing i need to do
about
getting a social security card or or
even the stimulus check it's just like
you know these things you shouldn't wait
on you know
like because
you might be in a worse situation in the
future where you can't even
do anything about it you know it's good
to just take care of things as soon as
as soon as they come into your mind to
get them done as quick as possible
and try to create a
foundation you know and don't
uh just keep screwing up everywhere
i really wish i i knew these things
before i got over
uh ambitious and and tried traveling the
whole us
and being in every region pretty much
it's just not worth it you know
all right sam thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah thank you very
much i wish you the best of luck out
here
thank you so much god bless
so did you living down streets have you
had bad stuff happen to you
yeah uh just uh
one time when i was in a southern
colorado colorado springs i uh
ran into some bad people uh i knew them
for a while as one guy
i hung out with him and his girlfriend
for a while
and uh everything seemed fine until uh
one night i was all alone in the trails
in the woods actually in a real cold
night and uh
i ran into this guy and uh
he told me like started going into
detail about how everything
was a lie about what he said he said you
know my name's not
joshua it's marcus and um
he said he's actually in a satanic cult
of 300 people
and uh and it was just uh
i started panicking he just told me uh
you're gonna die you know whatever
happens
you're gonna die and he said you could
give me money but i'm still gonna kill
you
and i try to make a uh whatever i could
uh barter for my life and uh
and he started stabbing me and
kept stabbing me and beat me with a
a big old stick and it was about like
six foot long and
up down like my face and he stabbed me
all here here i tried to defend myself i
mean you can
i have 23 23 stab ones
there's one here and uh
all throughout my arms legs they've
healed a lot though
yeah you can still see some of them yeah
and uh yeah i was lucky to
live through that um i
almost bled out i could feel all the
fluids leaving my body i could i was so
thirsty and by the time i ran away from
him
i uh made it to a walmart
and uh i didn't even have to say
anything everybody could see
i was just came out the woods and i was
bleeding head to toe
and they gave me a chair sat down in and
uh
called 9-1-1 and and i was so
thirsty by the time i i got to the er
i was bagging the uh medics for
sip of water and they're like no we
can't because it's going to be you know
i've got to give you surgery
and so i i i got healed
and it took about a week in the hospital
this is colorado yes sir um yeah
southern colorado colorado springs it's
uh
this is a pretty crazy place it's really
nice real outdoorsy
and um it's kind of like you know you
got the god squad kind of people like
to try to tell you to go only for god
and then there's also
is one of the places that i believe
i don't know if it's true or you know
how accurate is but they said it's one
of the first places that had a
satanic temple in america one of the
first
satanic temples so it's got a lot of
that
type of division there's a god squad and
then a lot of satanic people
i take it very seriously and uh
i had no idea about any of this stuff i
didn't know he was a bad person he
seemed just
just as normal as anybody you know very
normal
chill kind of person and him and his
girl
you know they were pretty cool people
you know he just kind of smoked pot with
me and we hung out and
he came to me saying a whole bunch of
stuff about how
i mean it was all a setup and everything
was just a lie
and we're not friends or anything like
that and it was
i don't know it was just you could hear
the panic bells just going off my mind
when that started happening
i didn't know what what was gonna happen
i
i thought for surely i was gonna die
that night you know
it was it was scary as hell this is
where you get traveling around
oh it's that this is where you get
traveling around the country you need
everybody in anything
you run into uh some some wild stuff
all right sam well thank you so much for
sharing your story yes thank you i wish
you the best of luck in your travels
yes sir thank you very much thank you
you